hey everyone welcome back to another
episode of the woodland podcast i'm
james marshall and this episode is
brought to you by waterlab coffee if you
haven't tried this brew yet go give this
freshly roasted coffee bean a try by
heading to waterlab.com and clicking the
coffee link up the top or even better if
you're a cafe and you want to start
selling some waterlet coffee beans go
buy the stuff in bulk and watch your
sales go up through the roof also as
always champion harness trainer regan
todd at todd's racing has helped this
podcast out massively so go give todd's
racing a follow on facebook and twitter
and there's a very exciting opportunity
coming soon in that space so look out
anyway i have a great guest for you
today so let's get into it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one thing that i've learned from the
podcast is just how up and down the
average rugby career is but the roller
coaster that today's guest has been on
is right up there he is one of the
biggest stars in world rugby he starred
for the man with two turbos and the
hurricanes before bursting onto the
international scene which included
carving up at the 2015 rugby world cup
but on top of all that he's also
struggled with an unfair amount of
injuries back to back to back which has
been tough but one thing that anyone
who's played with this guy will know
that he is one of the most genuine lads
in the game who's had an influence on so
many guys careers and lives it is of
course the one and only the man himself
milner scatter welcome scards oh mate
what an intro jeez he's you're fun um
you're going bloody well at this and i
think you probably left out
um the key
sort of fact i think from all that sort
of rugby career and experiences
um an unreal mentor who who took me
under his guidance
and
uh
yeah i guess everything was upwards from
there and and kickstarted fixed all that
uh
mate well going through your career it
all did start to happen at 2014 but i
cannot take any credit for that
i do we will touch on that because that
was one of the most that was one of the
weirdest things nehemia nascar had just
come into the hurricane's environment
mark hammett asked me if i could be his
mentor
and i feel that uh small senior guys
were given mentors and most of the kids
coming in were about 18 but then i've
been given you who was probably 10 times
more professional than me already
and already an absolute wizard i was
like come on hammer what am i supposed
to do with this guy he's already the
king now jeez i've probably owe a
massive thank you to hammer for uh for
making you my uh menswear and me your
mentee
man i put it on my cv i am officially
your mentor but i'm not taking any
credit for it but i could maybe make
some money from that down the track if
you're my one and only mentee look look
at what you've done holy heck i reckon
bro what a what a mentor
you were getting into that too weren't
you i saw uh you put up the other day
that you were looking to start doing
some mentoring
yes yeah um
i guess well i think about like all the
cool opportunities we get through rugby
and you know how to go into schools and
and do skills and drills and speak to
some of the young kids you know i get
like a bit of a buzz out of that and
just seeing how
sort of fizz the kids get and
probably just alongside that speaking to
my experiences um you know my eyes and
lows and and trying to just impart a
little bit of
um
i don't know wisdom or
life lessons that they can use and so
yeah bro that's something i'm trying to
explore um
just running some sort of like mentor
programs um
yeah just to help out the next
youth coming through bro mate you'd be
so good at that i'd be king to jump on
there and be
guided by you
well i'm getting you in his official
guest player you'll be
getting after you run the program on
mentoring
with the 101.
but on all seriousness though um
you've always been good at that like
your relationship with fans throughout
your career you've been one of the best
players that i've ever seen in terms of
being able to i guess communicate with
your fans and your fans all adore you
they love your side step but what you do
to them about giving your time you've
always been pretty special at that oh
geez thanks jimmy
um
for me i probably remember when i was a
little kid and i hear a lot of other
athletes speak about there um sort of
times there's a younger younger sports
ball sports boy coming up and the
heroes would um you know just give up
whether it's five seconds just to say
hello and and
a smile or photo and an autograph you
know just means the world so
um for me to be able to do that bro i
don't
yeah it just takes
five seconds out of your time and it
could make someone's day and something
that they always remember which is
a cool position to be in and i think
part of that bro like going a little bit
deeper it's
always been a person that finds it hard
to say no and so that probably comes in
a bit of a
a detriment just to
you know spread myself
i guess too much in terms of um
yeah doing things for other people but
at the same time bro i get a lot of uh
meaning and a lot of joy out of doing
that as well
mate you're a good kid anyway mate what
are you what are you up to at the moment
because i know you're back with manuela
too assistant coach i saw your name down
one of the great coaches um are you are
you still available to play yes yeah so
i've taken up um
a planning coaching role back at 102
again this is probably i was trying to
count how many
years from my first year there i think
it's like my 12th season or 11th season
so
you're definitely one of the quarrels in
the team but um
playing coaching role uh unfortunately i
haven't got the selection um
responsibility in terms of what my
coaching role is but
i'm available yeah still available to
play um
training and stuff with the boys and
just doing a bit of coaching yeah just
game strategy and a bit of ipp stuff on
the side so um yeah help out pete and
and greg and
jamie booth is is a part of the coaching
stuff now that poor buggers had a
friend frontal injury so it's good to
have knowledge of the game and just his
leadership and a coaching capacity too
bro so
exciting times it's a little bit of a
different dynamic i think like sort of
going from that playing to coaching yeah
i'd have to get you to give me a few
tips and stuff as well
apparently you've been just filling it
on the coach in front um you're very
young for the boy so
geez
yeah i'll be hitting you out bro mate
whatever you've done for those turbos
though they're on fire the first couple
rounds unlucky not to get the win over
canterbury yeah well i actually started
a bit late into the piece so i kind of
claimed that
well i hate to see them after
yeah exactly i was going to say look out
from here on in um
but yeah they've
got a lot of
not to say that the boys in the past
haven't been awesome players but there's
been a few
probably over a dozen new
new layers from out of the region that
have come in um
a few good players in key positions like
brett cameron um it's been he's been
killing it and good to get him back home
mission away i know he's
from wanganui just up the road a bit but
um now he's been awesome brian i think
yeah it's exciting but i think that
covers stop that run a little bit and
but yeah i know there's probably worse
things to be complaining about than just
getting back on the rugby field yeah and
how's your shoulder feeling shoulder's
good bro yeah it's um still hanging in
there sort of got through
he had a couple of years
just recently just trying to rehab and
get it back to um
get it back to fitness where i could be
playing again and got back out on the
field for mile two last year sort of
strung a whole season together and then
um we got through some footy this year
so shoulder's good bro yeah what
percentage do you reckon it's at like
what's what's really stopping you from
being picked at the moment is it your
shoulder or um
yeah it's there's a few different
conversations and a few different
um answers to that question which i've
posed many times is
probably differing opinions but in my
opinion um
ego aside yeah it is probably
um the shoulder and just trying to get
that confidence back yes um
i find it's hard bro because yeah like
we were touching on those years of like
2015 and
was out for 2016 but those are sort of
what people compare my level and ability
to which is something that i compare
myself to like to set that sort of
standard and have their own expectation
of
where i want to take my game and how i
want to perform every time
it's a tough
tough marker i guess to compare myself
against them yeah
but in saying that it's a challenge and
something that i'm you know still keen
to push to get to that level even or
even higher no
oh well hopefully hopefully we can see
you back out on that track shortly after
this lockdown finishes but anyway we've
got a massive bit of a run sheet to get
through uh unbelievable career i'm
looking forward to this one but we've
got to start at the start like all good
stories uh what was it like when a young
side stepped his way out oh um
i don't know where to start on that like
a lot of my
upbringing very during my youth i played
heaps of such obviously like not being
the biggest um biggest fellow running
around you know i loved playing touch
rugby my older brother all my family
all my mates and that would probably
either be training or playing most
nights of the week um growing up in the
metropolis of palmerston north so
the touch scene was was absolutely
humming um back then for me as a young
fella growing up and
that sort of
i don't know develop those little soft
skills around footwork and and catch
pass and
sort of reading you know defense setups
and all that sort of thing which is
still something i try and implement into
my game now uh and then from
from there bro i actually started oh i
played
rugby at high school went to queen
elizabeth college um give qc a big shout
out um
i was lucky enough to make the first and
the only fifteen we had one team
yeah tracking pretty well to to make
that team in and be captain for a few
games and and be the goal kicker and
different positions because i was
probably the one that turned up to most
of the trainings
um
and yeah from there it was it was kind
of
weird like i didn't make any rec teams
growing up um because i was at a small
school we sort of
weren't really looked at for the one or
two age great scenes
and
yeah i don't know just it was what it
was
and then i actually shifted to league um
in my first couple years out of high
school and went over to sydney for two
years to play in this world cup the
under 20s
uh so that was a cool experience bro
like the training mentality
of
yeah probably south australia inspiring
sort of their old school
mine suit like we had a
gary cardon was his name um over and at
the bulldogs bro and he was this old
following they were just
it was like
a drill sergeant on
roids in terms of like the training we
did and
the workouts and the conditioning
sessions and we used to just get smashed
for pretty much every every day and
um that was just a massive
eye opener for me i think sort of
being over in a whole different country
being away from family just getting
thrashed every day like training for
those that was real tough but
yeah i think that sort of set me up in
terms of you know what was the what was
to come from there i didn't actually
crack nrl which is which was my dream
and my goal after the two years and
twenties so i came home back to palmy
and then uh
yeah switched back to rugby and started
playing club i broke my back and pun had
you played league before you'd gone over
or did you just been scouted from your
rugby days um
no so i played like from the age of six
i think two up to ten so like true
yeah like first sort of sport i played
league before rugby
um
but then during high school sort of
switched to union because he wasn't
really much of a lead confident on me
for
kids and so
yeah that was my first sort of taste at
it and then i actually moved down to
wellington
my last
half of my seventh form year
and joined up with david lomax in this
league academy that he ran out in the
hut
and then he had contacts over an aussie
bro and a few of us got the opportunity
to go over and trial
and then um yeah there was little ride
and stayed over there the pre-season and
hung around for a few more years
crazy and what was it like at that
cannery bulldogs set up like other than
the hard training you were obviously a
young kid what was your living sort of
experience like uh bruce i moved around
sort of a few different living
arrangements i stayed with a cousin and
her family out
by parramatta
as though it was tough bro i was having
to like catch a bus two trains walk
about 20 minutes just to get to training
because everything's like
sydney's massive burn everything's so
spread out so it'll take a good couple
of hours
via public transport just to get to
training and then the same thing going
home or
doing a bit of teacher's aid work over
there working in
like a sports store bros
it was a bit of a grind but
i even talking about it now like i look
back at it thinking far out that sort of
you know builds a bit of resolve and but
a life life experience like this to what
i went through so what what stopped you
from getting it nrl crack because you
were carving it up yeah i think you and
benny barber was it you guys had a some
unreal combo out there
from memory
holder i only played like a couple of
games
with ben because he um he was a year
above me but he was in the ball saying
bro he was killing it he was still
eligible for twenties
um but he was playing first grade and
then like ripping it up so i think i'm
out and he played a couple of games with
him um at the doggies and
we had some pretty good players bro like
there's
josh jackson um i think he's captain of
the bulldogs now dale fernando can
um who's played origen yeah who else is
born
martin sopo sam casiano
tim la fire
yeah there's a few boys that sort of
kicked on
um
the first grade and
i don't know at the time the bulldogs
were stacked very from their first grade
squad through to like even reserve new
south wales cup so
they just said oh look we
don't really yeah we haven't got a spot
for you um
[Music]
yeah sorry about that and
all the best so bro it was funny because
i was trying to think of like what what
to do after that and i had family my
brother was living up in brisbane at the
time so i was like if i might just go up
to queensland and just work or go across
to perth wa got family there and just
work in the mines and
just tried everybody in some coin and
and just live over there for a bit and
just have a break from from footy and
just experience other stuff but um
yeah at the same time i was pretty
homesick so i just yeah made the call to
come back to par me and get into the
get into union mate that's crazy crazy
to hear we almost lost you to the mines
that would have been mad
so you just went back to manual too on
your own terms with no contract just
playing club rugby yeah pretty much bro
like i still had
heaps of friends and that back in um
back in palm at the time like one
good friend of mine is
johnny leota he was sort of a legend
around one or two rugby circles played
down at lands for a bit
and so we we grew up um
playing touching that together and he
actually got me to go
to his club marist um when i come back
from aussie and he took me under his his
wing and
did heaps of sort of skills and training
and gym sessions and all that and
was probably yeah thanks to him i had
heaps of people worry about he was one
key
key figure that um helped me when i got
back to parmie and
put in a good word with
wren's dave rennie at the time
um just uh i don't know have a look at
me over club right then
and see how i'll go and i was lucky to
pick up a two of us contract at the end
of that season and you debuted pretty
quickly that year 2a ah yeah that was my
first year with the turbos it might have
been might have been an awesome game at
home
yeah i remember playing games like ready
ranger he was in a man or he still is
the man but he was killing it at the end
so that was a bit of a buzz bro playing
against someone obviously but then also
for us with the turbos we had you know
like aaron cruden
um aaron smith
callum gibbons oh they're all lads
you know speaking of
an absolute legends bro so
yeah um i was pretty lucky to be in the
mix with his awesome fellas and awesome
rugby players that helped um
grow my game and take it to another
level did you feel ready to play when
you were given the shot did you feel
like you were ready for that level um
no probably not like
it's probably a common theme
through most of my career bro just
getting thrust into
like
the next level up so quick like
one season that club been playing itm oh
sorry there was probably a gap between
npc to super like a
three or four seasons before that step
up but then that super that all blacks
was you know that same season as well um
but i guess yeah you never really
know until you're
until you're in there doing it right so
yeah i was kind of just
riding the wave and
trying to just work on my game and had
awesome people around me who experienced
followers another one was craig clear
and casey stone junior tomasi farmer
guys who you know
helped improve my game heaps and did you
have an injury the following year is
that sort of what stopped you from
progressing a little bit quicker um
geez can i think of my injury history
we're going back a few for this one
i think that might have been
i think i had just like um real [ __ ]
like soft tissue yeah yeah andreas that
might have been like a tight calf my
hammies used to go ahead
which i could say was from being too
quick but um yeah not enough nordic
kills i don't think
but yeah they can you just go and all
sort of yeah just throw like real niggly
couple of weak injuries that were kind
of
just compound and so it wasn't
yeah major ones until until their
shoulder but yeah it was kind of yes
that second year turbo's kick-started
little
niggles which yeah injury runs bro bit
frustrating eh
yeah but then the following year you
must have had a reasonably good season
to get the call into the hurricanes
wider squad
and then that's when what we sort of
already talked about where this career
sort of really looked to fast track
pretty quickly um
yeah i can't remember what yeah was it
trying to think of that game in levin
it was like a
mid-season one did you play that oh yeah
that's right yeah against crusaders yeah
because a lot of the your guys keynes
boys were away with the all blacks and
um i know yeah me and kelly from one or
two came in
just to find that and from there i just
started or kept having conversations
with um
um and then he just said oh look like
yeah play well and
uh mpc this season and we'll try and get
you into like a wider training contract
uh for 2014 so
yeah sort of
happened from that opportunity very just
getting that game in your guys mid
season break or something against
crusaders
mate those games are so underrated as a
player i reckon because so many
opportunities come from those games that
people don't realize people often think
oh i've got to play a development game
or no this this game don't really want
to play this not on tv that sort of
stuff but it's crazy how many guys get
opportunities from playing well in those
games 100 there'll be like so many and
i think even thinking back to that time
that might have been the only one that
on the
like the season calendar whereas now
we've got a whole
sort of five six games of like kings
development games or all the super rugby
um teams have
heaps of games with guys that are just
like floating under the radar
and
club or
provincial unions right they just get
like one crack
rip it up and then suddenly you know
they'll get caught into the train or
people are talking about them which yeah
yeah it's pretty cool but like you say
we're so taken for granted yeah i agree
so then you you're into the hurricanes
environment now how did you find that
obviously there's a lot of legends at
the time in that setup you had the ma
the conrad's all of those guys and how
did you find meeting all these boys it's
pretty daunting um yeah those two names
that you
mentioned as well as like the corey
james the julian saviers the jimmy
marshalls
you know like
just sort of walking around like far out
these all my idols and
i'm sitting next to them and the
changing rooms and running out to the
training paddock with them so
um and the fact that i was like far out
was almost i don't know if the terms
that imposter syndrome yeah
we like have to
almost
tell yourself
so much that you're worthy of being
there just because you're like far out
these guys are like all blacks and i'm
just coming out of
npc and these guys are legends so it's
like i'm just some
fellow who's just rocked up and and
kings have a crack and um
[Music]
you're pretty pumped up but
like what i've learned bro is like
having that sort of mindset and speaking
to heaps of different people like you
get chosen for a reason like you
wouldn't be there if you weren't good
enough and and just to have
trust and not only like the coaches were
picking you but like in your own
abilities so
um
with that bra even speaking to guys like
yourself and the cj's and you guys made
me feel pretty relaxed and pretty
comfortable and you know and at home and
um
even like when i try and speak to other
younger players or new people in certain
environments where i sort of take what i
learn from you guys and try and make
them feel welcome because i know
how
how like freaky it is and how sort of
scary it can be but then just by having
a conversation and
uh reassurance bro it sort of puts you
at ease and it allows you to just focus
on going out and and enjoying it and
playing rather than like wow what about
this what if i stuff like what
that's crazy to hear about that because
i never pictured you to be one of those
guys i always thought you were really
confident in your own ability you had
all the skills everyone was sort of just
waiting for you to get an opportunity
because they knew that you were gonna
explode like you did so it's interesting
to hear that you had those um
self-doubts coming into that environment
which i never really expected from you
yeah it's um
it's funny bro because like
even i guess through my journey with
like mental well-being and that i
probably wouldn't have been out with an
articulator or sort of understand it
properly so at the time like i might
have been
sort of feeling it in a way but i didn't
actually know how to express that and
it's only through i guess
like these last four or five years and
getting a little bit older and life
experience and a bit more self-awareness
you're actually like oh far out that's
what i was feeling at the time and
that's what i was going through with
like you don't know what you don't know
and so
yeah it's an interesting one bro like
you're not to say that if i did feel
those things but it's probably like i
don't actually know how to
like communicate it in the way that i
yeah that i do now yeah
that makes sense does make sense and
it's a hard thing to communicate isn't
it like how do you
start a conversation with someone about
that when you're going into a new game
who who do you feel comfortable enough
to go up and tell them about your
self-doubts and things like that yeah
totally bro it's um
hitting the nail on the head in terms of
how
you know that conversation in particular
but so many other
conversations in that space regarding
like our
you know our issues or things we're
struggling with or we're not coping
because it's like how do we
how do we start that conversation um
how do we build that trust or those
relationships to be able to go into
those spaces and
all right yeah i think that's yeah such
a like key issue
or
heaps that we need way more educational
pieces and tools on how to actually
go about that but it's um
yeah
it's interesting well as your mentor i
feel like i probably should have picked
up on some of those cues and
initiated some of those chats i've let
you down
i definitely do not feel let down by
but then following that season with the
keynes you went back with the turbos and
that's where you lit up the competition
that yeah turbo's had a really
successful season i think you were named
player of the year in the championship
and you guys won that championship that
year yeah every 2014 we're
yeah i don't know for some reason yeah
we were humming that year we had like a
lot of experienced guys who were
probably into like their third or fourth
year
mpct um the same team as well that we've
had for the previous few seasons and so
there was that um
that continuity that what if what's that
term that gets shipped around that
cohesion
it was a big factor in our success and
um good culture as well there's another
one
uh we all the boys just enjoyed each
other's company and we sort of knew what
we were trying to do on the field as
well in terms of our game plan
uh and yeah everyone like from one to
a sport of 30 close to 30 you know
everyone was just wanting to compete and
and be the best and everyone just
bought you know those sort of eight nine
ten out of ten games most weeks and yeah
very stoked that we're out of winning
that or the championship division that
year against um our
arch enemies up up the line of that book
space so yeah yeah that was a cool year
for us and and for me personally because
i think
that back into that year i was lucky
enough to get picked in the maori all
blacks team as well to go to japan for a
couple of games and um
oh yeah just the
how much do you know the maori culture
means to me and and how proud i am of
that to get named for that for me and my
family was huge
and what was that tour like well that
was
so i was like my first experience in
like a black jews feel like a you know
representative team and
for it to be based around
like maori culture but it was was like
real cool because
it enabled me or allowed me to reconnect
with with my culture so like very most
team meetings would start with like a
couple of songs
um
giving like a bit of a brief history on
all the boys like where they're from
like different areas in different
regions
around the country
and so as well as trying to perform on
the field but i was sort of like you're
you know learning about who we are and
where we're from
which
or you know talk about identity and
things like that that's
that's massive bro so that was a cool
cool experience and then also like
playing with
pretty much most of the team were all
super rugby players
um
incredible leaders and to go to japan as
well was
it was pretty surreal it was awesome
could you speak maori i speak a little
bit like i can read it um
i can understand like what people are
saying but i struggle to
sort of hold a conversation like i can
kind of yeah chuck in a few words here
and there
but in terms of actually being able to
converse um
fully broken i struggle but it's
something i'm still here trying to chip
away at
um black around um by increasing my
vocab trying to figure out synthetic
structures trying to just be able to
speak like hold a conversation in
interior so i've got like heaps of books
and resources um
doing a few online courses i'm quite
lucky because it's my family and i've
got mates in that they can
speak it fluently so every time i sort
of get on the phone to my mom or my
sister i try and just tell him to
speak to me like fully interview and
there'll just be radio signs for a
little bit well
what they're saying but um
it's all about there's more quality time
that we get to spend together as well
100
and then so following your minor 2
season where you lit it up you earned a
full squad spot with the hurricanes and
then the rest is history pretty much oh
you got your debut against the force
first touch see you later set up one of
the greatest tries in hurricanes history
and
um
milner scatter the legend was born
wasn't he
yeah
yeah i don't know if
probably jules can take you know
most of the
recognition from there that i just
ran about five meters and passed it to
him to run 60 and bounce off about four
more
and the left up to that's fire but um
yeah that was
was quite funny bro because when you
speak about like injuries just before i
think that's well yeah part of injuries
and and just not getting picked around
missing the first two games i think we
we started in africa and i was actually
touching go to travel because we had our
last
it was a preseason game in auckland
against the blues and i think i tweaked
my ncl oh true so boyd
and the medical team were like oh farah
how bad is it um should we just keep
coming in zero wait till we come home
and
he's lucky enough to get on the plane
and be the food dog for a couple of
weeks and enjoy um
what's the job as a
monty casino yeah yeah yeah
parked up next to calum given and get a
few uh strawberry milkshakes
um poolside and then uh yeah but i lucky
enough to get my get a crack uh when we
flew back through perth against the
force
so you felt ready going into that game
against the force you were ready to have
your crack now
yeah yeah well partly because i've done
a couple of weeks training at altitude
like yeah
i'm more than ready uh
but in saying that though we came off
the back of two wins and so trying to
understand
yeah i want to be playing but what's
what's best for the team as well just to
know in terms of winning three games on
the road
um to start off that season that'll be
massive and
i'm not
here just to keep the boys
you know that consistency and keep the
same team out there really be what's
best for the team but at the same time i
was kind of like no no no give me
get me in there and boy um yeah bailed
me up at breakfast i think one of the
mornings that just said oh but here
we're gonna give you start your they'll
bring you off the bench this week so i
was like
you did it
you beauty all right and mate that
season you were just on absolute fire
every game you'd come up with
highlights that most people would be
proud of to have throughout their career
in every single game it was just
whatever you touch turn to gold and
you're beating defenders left right and
center
how did how does it feel when you're in
that moment you know you're you you know
you're on a run i've never been in it
ah well see i've seen um
one one run of yours that just popped to
i'm sure you beat like just about the
whole team i was like well mate i might
have to find that footage and uh bring
it back up because
thanks for bringing that up uncle's in
the 60s 23rd minute bro so
i'll grab it but i don't know in all
seriousness like
i just
wanted to
express myself i guess like
have a crack from anywhere everywhere
every time i got the balls i will
just try not to get tackled
um i've been practicing this side step
for about 20 odd years now sometimes
i'll put it together
and see how it goes um
but very like
even when i talk to people about their
cane season like you
are you got to look at our team by who
we had
the fire power throughout our whole
squad and so
you know when i'm playing outside
the all black
midfield um an all black first five and
all black
half back
pretty much you know what was it just
you and i that were
yeah you were an overlap not long after
you you went straight in there oh it's
like far out do you and i rock off to
see who's going to be the anchor player
in the game
all right so i don't know for me just
shows the
what you can do when you're playing
around like incredible players and
there's a defensive coach for i don't
know putting a defensive head on and
and previewing the hurricanes you're
probably like oh yep sweet we'll just
defend up against all these players and
leave this fella because
yeah what about um the final um that
year was such an awesome year we're
winning games left right and center but
then come to the big final
the big showdown we we don't quite do
enough what are your memories from it
um yeah but i don't
i don't know it's kind of like it but
very very distant memory
but
it was probably just that whole
i don't know i hear the word
complacency get bandied about and
sort of probably already playing playing
the game before we got to it like that
week there were a whole lot of
like celebrations and things like that
and creating all those hypebra and
i know for me i probably got caught up
in it and
didn't um
in terms of my own individual
performance like i wasn't
up there in terms of what i
what i want to be proud of was probably
a you know generous six
um where's your
other games in the season or sort of
humming and
probably the whole um enormity of the
game you know having a sellout uh we
pack a hype during the week
um
probably going into the game as
favorites as well
you know we played the landers a few
weeks prior and napier and put a score
on them and yeah probably just probably
weren't as hungry and all those sorts of
words and
when that whistle went it's interesting
one a big finals footy when the when the
pressure comes on like you talk about
that week that crowd it was it was an it
was an awesome occasion but so
disappointing to a full shorter
yeah but yeah
incredibly uh
deflating i think bruh one thing i'm
always pissed off at when i've all
gotten over a little bit but
after the game so i had like heaps of
family like we all the boys that and a
lot of support friends in there that
made the trip not only for that game but
throughout the season and
because we lost
and felt pretty disappointed like i
think i don't know if all of us went
into the changing room straight after
but i went in there and didn't actually
like go and see my family in the crowd
and i was kind of like yeah i feel stink
and i'm having a wedge in the sulk
um but like that's a big regret for me
and something i don't
i've learned from that is like whether
we work nor we lose like still actually
acknowledging people who have
traveled who paid money who had
supported
throughout the whole season and
for me to just like
ghost them and be like naf i don't want
to see anyone i'm having an assault when
i'm going to the change rooms
just felt real stink bro and um yeah
that's that's a big sort of another
thing that i remember from that
that final as well mate i like that and
that's so common i mean not often you
get after a loss like that you'll see
the players still walking around doing
the signatures but may if you change
your mentality around like what you're
talking about that would be it'd be
awesome to see teams after a loss still
going and acknowledging their supporters
or their family and stuff i like that
yeah so i reckon um like you can
definitely be pissed off but save it
you know save until you get back into
the change rooms like
that's not to say that you yeah
to just be like oh [ __ ] we lost all good
all good
you know speed is like still feel sting
but
do it in the right way um
and yeah that's sort of something i
will try
yeah pass on or you carry on to
carry on those behaviors as well right i
like it and then obviously from that
year you're on absolute fire did you
know that you were gonna sort of be
called into the all blacks did you have
an inkling that you were going to be in
the frame
no bro not at all um
yeah like
you have dreams and aspirations and
stuff to make
teams and that but like to actually
for it to be like you know reality has
has seemed so much even like crazier and
so much further from what's actually
going on so
no i don't didn't get it angling
whatsoever like you'll get the izzy
daggs or corey james the charles pierce
house julian saviers like
all right outside baxter new zealand
rugby has always have always been you
know just
like
20 that could easily trap on a black
jersey and i don't think my name was one
of them
but
funny yarn like i remember when the team
got announced then um hannah and i were
at home in wellington and i actually
like put on a feed put on some porridge
some oats in the microwave
about to have a feed and him was like oh
watch the announcement i was like oh no
waste of time i'm just gonna
have a feed i was in the kitchen uh
waiting for the microwave to finish and
i just hear they're like yelling out
screaming come on come in here like
just losing it and now we went in like
that's like i thought the last of my
name getting um like along the bottom of
the screen
i was just like nah
you're taking the first like what's
going on
sure this is g up and then yeah the
phone went berserk and yeah bro it was
happening
mate that's awesome hey i've got a bit
of goosebumps listening to that that's
cool oh yeah it's um
like beyond
beyond like my imagination is the
feeling actually witnessing it happening
like
yeah in front of me and watching it on
tv and
yeah it was just crazy bro so surreal
and then going into the all blacks
environment how did you feel because you
you spoke about probably being pretty
intimidated at first going into the
manor two
environment then a few years later now
you're walking into probably one of the
most intimidating environments in in the
world what was it like
yeah well like i think we're first
assembled and we went into this big sort
of big team meeting room and
i think first person i saw might have
been like kevin milam and then
tony woodcock um richard mccall and then
dan carter and i was like
all right like
what do i say to these guys
oh hey mate hey i'll like feel like
excuse myself
funny now when i look back at it
and think to you first meeting them and
then
all the stuff with trainings and
meetings and games playing alongside
them whereas uh
it was crazy it was funny though because
we actually
flew into christchurch i think we first
assembled there but we landed at the
same time as the
uh landers boys oh yeah it's at all
let's go like
maybe a few days after the final
and it was like yeah
they're all the opposites in terms of
you know energy and morale like you get
all that candy boys just like
looking like we wanted to fight someone
and they land with boys like we're just
high on life for happy years and yeah
yeah
we couldn't really understand why oh
oh that's classic
and did you feel comfortable when you
first made your debut because i from
memory it was against um australia and
you scored a couple of tries too i think
i don't know if you ever feel
or like levels of comfort like playing
in the orbits there's so much um life
and so much pressure around it but i was
lucky enough because i actually missed i
think it was the first
couple of games like the boys played
i might have played one game in new
zealand and then they traveled to south
africa
and then i was
your name for that third game and so
that was a
that was an interesting week because we
spent half the week in auckland i think
they wanted to change up like the usual
group so i think
most of the time you travel and you
spend the whole week in in the city
preparing but we went over there on like
a
wednesday so we just had the one
training
and then the captains run and then play
so that was probably good because i was
able to i don't know just i was used to
being in auckland or
like being at home whereas being in like
aussie again and
like the media and stuff like that
probably would have been a bit
overwhelming
so that made me a bit more comfortable
um
what threw me out of my comfort zone was
our training very on like
it's like those big training sessions
uh towards the back end of the week yeah
and i i remember the experience
overweightly like i was defending on the
right wing
getting like a half way 50 meter line
out
but i think the boys the dd's did like a
two pass and kicked to the opposite
corner right i just got on my like
jets to try and cover that back corner
and i wasn't looking for my turn i
probably sprinted about five meters and
smashed into steve hansen
but you know
so you know highlight the coaches are
like uh flopped it all around the field
and they're all like wiped out saying oh
lying out here scrum here all blacks
blah blah blah so he was sort of just
smack bang in the middle of the field
and i just was like watching the ball
like be kicked
this gun that burns smacked into him
and um i'd like to know where to help
him up or just carry on like play on and
get the ball
and
yeah i was like oh [ __ ] great sweet mean
just before my debut two days out i just
like smoked the coach
um
and yeah he was all good like he
it ended up getting played like the
following week in one of the team
meetings because it was captured on film
i yeah it was bears kick back to the
other corner take off smash steve hands
and then he's just like
just like huddled over on the ground
yeah i'm glad he found it amusing
eventually but uh
yeah like how am i still in the team for
this week
that's so good what is what is shag like
was he was he intimidating bloke
yeah i found them pretty insane but
ain't like
well
after you get to know him he's pretty
he's got like a real good understanding
of new players and like experienced
players so like
like if you're new like he understands
that it's so it's a high pressure
situation so he tries to make you feel
as comfortable as possible while i'm
just having
conversations like i remember
i was like me wise uh cody taylor were
sort of the new boys in there
name for that campaign sops
and like steve was always sort of
just by us telling us like what we were
seeing giving us little tips like so
much encouragement
and i think that was um
yeah that was different because you hear
sort of stories about him or you see how
he interacts with the older players yeah
it's almost like that um like being the
youngest and in the family like the
youngest
siblings yeah
next level to be able to feel as like
comfortable and at ease is
so important and so he yeah he was
pretty pretty good at doing that by
encouraging us like having conversations
with us
not
expecting us to
you know score three tries or nail every
single thing it's just like cool here's
a couple of things to focus on uh
reminding us that we're like good enough
to be there another situation which
helped bro was
so their leadership group
and gilbert anoka
that first week we assembled that he got
all the young boys together and just
said oh look like
if you guys have any um
issues or you know you're finding it
tough just come and talk to us like it
was pretty much just like a chicken
chicken group and to have
because rita was there as well probably
three or four the
the big dogs
like they wanting to get get to know us
and show that they they cared you know
mean heaps for us and
i know like going forward and playing a
few games and stuff like that there was
always um yeah something that helped us
get through that
that's cool to hear so then the world
cup later that year how was it going to
that did you were you expecting to be
named now because you'd obviously played
well in every opportunity you were given
today or not really because i think i'd
only played yeah so that debut game and
then the following week in auckland
before they
were getting into the announcements of
the world cups what's so
like
man grateful for those two games like
they played for the all blacks but
sweet i'll just look forward to npc and
back with one or two and then yeah i
remember being at home in palmy at my
parents house and and shandy the all
blacks manager run up and uh you gave me
the good news
and so we had to get down to wellington
because they did a big announcement at
the big squad reveal at parliament
um
but even then very like
guys who missed out like charles piertel
fizzy
um cory jane and they were all in their
uh rugby championship that put us though
sport that i was in and bro but when i
speak of like corey jane at the kings
like he was still awesome and that all
black set up but izzy bag was
very like absolute like led we room room
together a few times and very he was he
was awesome to just to learn from and
see how he how he operates yeah
yeah and so for them like
for me i was like oh yeah those guys are
showing so
they'll be in there and i'll be cheering
them on um yeah when they when they go
to the world cup yeah that is buzzy yeah
i forget that all those players missed
out on that uh world cup squad but the
squad that you took was still one of the
best all black sides in history i reckon
looking at that squad it was so stacked
that had all the greats in one squad
yeah bro like so many greats and i think
what held that team together especially
come those like playoff games was a lot
of them had played 2007 and then 2011 as
well um so having all these legends but
then there were a few sort of younger
and experienced players who were just
trying to bring fizz and ring fizz and
energy to the group
um
so i was yeah a real good balance for
our thought and
all the coaching and
support staff did a good job to
sort of fuse that together and um
like remember our game plans leading
sort of throughout the pool
round robin games we're trying to sort
of
hold back and not show too much
and save it for the
without getting ahead of ourselves i
think we're really in the finals but
just trying to keep things up our sleeve
for the
for the quarters bro and uh
yeah
france game and and carter for that
quarterfinals
yeah bro that was something else that
was crazy man
did you feel the extra pressure at a
world cup or just playing for the all
blacks you were already feeling enough
pressure already did you feel the extra
pressure of a world cup um
yeah bro yeah to be honest and that it
was that first game um we played rg
want to say it was at wembley or one of
the big big stadiums over there which
had might have been like over a hundred
thousand and
the
south american like the rg supporters
probably just go mad i remember just
little pockets in the stadium and it was
almost like we were playing in
like buenos aires or something
that's how loud and how
how crazy it was and
um where i had an absolute shock of that
game too like um
yeah sunday
really in the second half suddenly made
a break down the
now my touch line and gave me an offload
i was just like right in the grip
basketball and i was like two meters
from the line and i dropped it oh true
oh [ __ ] here we go
and then two seconds after that all
couple of minutes argentina exited out
um
and then it was kind of just going out
by the outline but i thought i could
save it and keep it in i ended up like
touching it and hitting it in the window
so i was there lined up so i went from
like
a dead sea trial opportunity that was
just
being marched back about 60 meters and
we were filming a line out inside our
own half so
i think i only lasted about five more
minutes after that and got hooked oh i
did yeah sure
oh no and then
i remember like the
review on the monday
like that clip didn't even get showed
like about my like stuff-ups it was
it was like a kick that i didn't chase
um we had like a
set move off like a line up and i didn't
like reload and
get set properly and i would have been
through like a hole if i had have done
that and suddenly i was just getting
ripped and straight to the
so that was yeah like
that took a toll bros to go and see um
gilbert
anoka like the team
manager team psychologist that week just
to put some
processes some systems in place around
like just focusing on my ability um like
if i feel like i'm
thinking about like outcomes or whatever
or whatevs how to just be be present and
be back in the moment did you feel like
that worked yeah right yeah yeah yeah
i've had like um yeah it's probably
crazy but
getting into that first game i was kind
of like
almost felt
i'm not bulletproof's the right word but
because i was playing in the all blacks
i was like well far out i've got 14
other guys that are just going to rip up
and i can kind of
just goes through and pick my moment
here and there um because yeah just a
stupid mindset there really
but then
the following week um
it was namibia and i was just like nah
i'm
like hungry as my god even just
absolutely
like kill it just had this like killer
mindset and
um he felt way better after that game
came off the field like you know i had
heaps of energy i was doing what i
needed to do i was focused my
yeah work right was up there all those
sorts of things
and you learned this starting winger
spot for the big games didn't you so you
were the you were the starting right
wing come crunch time
yeah yeah yeah and it was
it was hard because uh no
weiss um
he had a few like nipples with his leg i
think he had
his break
right to world cup
um so i was sort of out of him and eye
for that right wing
spot and so
like he is an absolute beast that yeah
it was good competition between him and
i to try and get um that 14th spot i
know bender was another option if bodhi
wants to go to fullback but yeah i was
pretty glad that they had
been gone with me to
wear the 14 jumper yeah and then winning
the world cup talk to me about that like
one of the ultimate highs in sport i
guess but
how did it feel like you're pretty good
with explaining your emotions what's
winning a world cup like um
yeah but i was sort of like overwhelming
um
sort of being in a big stadium where
like there's so many things like
obviously
tens of thousands of people you can't
actually in a way you can't actually see
any things they're just like
it's like you're looking into the abyss
just hearing all this like
noise and stuff um
everyone's just like so happy and
so joyful very lucky look at like boys
were crying and stuff like that of tears
of joy
just everyone was just so happy and then
we did like a lap in the field and then
there was that incident when that boy
ran on the field oh yeah and the
security guard just went over the top
like
tackled him sonny gave him his middle
brother i was crazy because i saw it all
right then i was trying to fire out
what's going on they didn't know whether
to like push the
like security guard just lot for a child
like he's a 10 year old kid he's not
gonna
do anything to six foot four hundred and
ten shredded stunning williams
um
yeah that was that's pretty bizarre and
he got back around to like the tunnel
and help
um families and stuff with it so
it's about uh uh embrace of them and
just share with them what's cool bro but
i remember
i think was me talbot kubalo
they still had the little mini stage
left out on the on the field and
um we were doing like snow angels bro
with the campfire
what it looks so
so like funny and random made like these
three
regrowing men breaking clothes then our
angels and
everybody
thumbs up the feeling for us
oh living your good life and then 2016
you're probably looking to build off
that year and then um
injury struck one of many to start but i
think it was against the blues a the
first one
shoulder yeah yeah by round three and um
like you were saying because i don't
know if i've heard the tournament league
that second year syndrome yeah
so like
um
players will kill it
sort of their first year coming in like
the rookie year and then they have to
try and back it up and
like a lot of cases they don't uh
or heaps of reasons and so that was
uh something that was in the back of my
head trying to be like hey sweet i just
want to prove it to myself prove to
everyone else that it wasn't sort of a
fluke that 2015 year uh to build on that
but go to another level and
yeah brother i think i was around yeah
that round three up and open against the
blues
ended up dislocating my shoulder but i
was so
so like
innocuous so it's just a way that i've
been tackled
you know hundreds of times before and
for some reason my elbow kind of just
got jammed
and then my shoulder popped and i hadn't
had a dislocated shoulder before or any
sort of
shoulder injuries and so i was like fat
i know what's going on but i was pretty
sore
um and then the doc came on was like oh
you popped your shoulder and i was like
oh yeah so yeah what is yeah what does
that mean
um he said i'll work take out the tunnel
and get it put back in
so we did that and then um i was like oh
sweet like what's the
recovery for these sorts of injuries i
was thinking like maybe
a few weeks that month and then doc was
like oh nah you're going to be up for
about six months we're just going to get
surgery
and i was like
oh you're serious like
pretty gutted by just that realization
but thinking oh yeah maybe a few weeks
but then six months in the whole season
so we are sitting in the medical room i
was ready i was guarded bro like
in a bird cry and sort of didn't know
how to process
um
produces that feeling at that time i
just like gutted so um
yeah from
in a few weeks after that like getting
scans and trying to
figure out like what surgery looks like
what what the recovery is what my next
steps are
trying to count six months from now
what game am i going to be back for all
those sorts of questions and scenarios
um so yeah it was pretty tough and
i know what helped me very throughout
that was just trying to set little
milestones um
you know first and foremost just getting
getting through the surgery um and then
you know what the first week after that
looked like just taking it
day by day weeks week as opposed to
you know getting too [ __ ] up and
it's sort of future and off all right
i've got to
be doing this by one month or
six months time this is where i want to
be it's kind of like far okay today i'm
gonna
just do my rehab exercises chilly at
home
pool tomorrow i'll worry about that when
it comes
was there anything you didn't do in
terms of uh how you handled that that
you would have done differently looking
back oh yeah heaps bro like um you know
how i was saying
like
that
after that 2015 final like being pissed
off and showing it in a way that wasn't
good by just sulking going into the
change rooms like having
having spaces and um
different situations where you can
express your frustrations like
i used to be so short and grumpy like
with my wife like
to get her on a podcast
so many times and that's something i'll
definitely
wouldn't do again and something i've
learned
through my injuries is just sort of
having that
yet being gutted but then trying to have
that little space between how i
respond and what that response looks
like um
a few times like yeah i just wanted to
just stay at home they don't want to go
out in public because you know everyone
would be like oh yeah
how's your shoulder how's your shoulder
right it's like you just want to write
like a little trick
hand out these little cards to have the
answers on them here you go
yeah
yeah hundred percent just right like a
little um here today because
and
like looking at that as perspective
though like i know people just
you know cared and
just were supporting me and wanted to
know how i was doing and if i was doing
all good
but for me it just kept reiterating the
fact that i'm injured or far out the
fact that i can't
be trained now i can't be playing and so
just like this
keep putting me in this little rut
um
but yeah after a little while bro i came
to realize that
yeah people just care and just want to
know well majority you get some bricks
that are like oh you're in blue
yeah yeah you know retire give it up
like oh what do you
do you like getting injured or something
like that or all those sorts of random
random thoughts and questions how have
you handled those guys um
a library like sometimes i do get a bit
pity
and just like bite back and just be like
oh bro like you've honestly got no idea
of course i don't want to get injured on
purpose
right now i'm still training pretty hard
and like i feel like i have to
almost justify myself yeah
that's and it's like
what poorly just a little you know
sometimes you're just a profile picture
of a cat on
[Music]
facebook or like a race car i'm like why
am i referring to like a race car
um
which yeah finding music half the time
but
yeah but as
well as that like realizing you know the
people who truly matter and the opinions
that
you should value and
um
sort of be
listening to most of the times you know
your close friends and family like
you'll always be critics out there and
yeah
nice and then your run of injuries from
that shoulder was shocking at what
seemed to be injury after injury a lot
of them are the shoulder 2a yeah bro so
all of my
i had a broken
foot i think in there as well um
but yeah so that's 2016 you did my left
shoulder i was out for the whole i
missed that whole year so i got back
2017
and then
yeah i did my football so i
broke like the three or four middle
metatarsals
so they put me up for about three months
and then
um i got back just before the british
norrish lion store
and so that was sort of like a big
um
goal or objective to work towards was
trying to get picked in that
i only played two games so i spoke to
steve before the announcement you just
said oh look right yeah i played enough
footy to uh warrant getting back in the
squad for the lines tourist life i had
yeah like real gutted because it was
still a goal of mine but i ended up
playing for the maldives against them
and um
um
and then
got back
into the all blacks i think for the
championship in the 2017 barone my other
shoulder that's right uh in africa
so i was out for another
sort of six
six to nine months
got back 2018
got back in the championship squad again
for the blacks um and entered my left
shoulder and
japan
that will exist in japan and then i was
out
that was probably the second surgery and
i had to have another cleanup on that
2019 year
since the yearbook
did you find the injuries easier to deal
with or harder because there were so
many ah harder very like
my initial thought was that i would find
it easier because i yeah cool just that
whole
or you put like rinse and repeat in
terms of my rehab and and mine says bro
but it was like
that's probably where i came um stuck in
that thinking like oh that whole
resilience yeah of um showing that with
my left shoulder i'll just do the same
to my right but
what was different though was like my um
were the goals that i was working
towards
so after 2016 like that initial that
first injury was like [ __ ] no i wanted
to get back playing i had all these
second gear syndrome wants to kill it
again this year pretty wrong wrong
and then i was trying to get back for
the lines then it changed to being like
okay so we don't get back for 2017 lines
did i make that but they made the all
blacks got injured again so i was kind
of like everything
kept resetting itself yeah in terms of
what my outlooks were
and then
um 2018
i was like i need to get back out of my
field to play some good footy to try and
push for 2019's world cup
and then got injured into 2018 which
sort of was a ride off my
2019 year and then i was just like fine
now now what um
yeah so it keep changing your brain
almost here would have to say that it
was harder each
each time because um
yeah the challenges or the
the goals and the objectives i was
trying to achieve with different next
time and i was almost like a different
person
it was interesting and then you're you
signed with the highlanders last year
how was that one yeah it was um
there's an interesting move so i was
sort of tossing up whether to stay at
the canes um
or
yeah an opportunity to go down south and
i just wanted like a change
um
sort of a new club
new play players a bit of a new town
like down and dunno's and
um yeah bro i enjoyed it down there it
was probably
hard because a lot of that time was
spent rehabbing my shoulder and so
um similar sort of mindset to how it
would have been and so on was trying to
you know you want to go to go somewhere
and hit the ground running and impress
from the get-go and
start building relationships and
um you know adding value where you can
and for me to still be
uh rehabbing burroughs quite tough but
um all the boys and all the management
up here down there were real supportive
and i enjoyed my time down there from
from what i've heard from guys like chow
and
obviously solomon was on the other on
the podcast the other day how highly
they spoke about the
influence that you had on the
highlanders team and the culture even
though you didn't get probably as much
game time as you probably would have
hoped um what you are doing in terms of
around the environment down there
sounded like you're having a massive
influence yeah brian um i think it's
easy because
like
a lot of you know all the layers down
there um
yeah run a pretty cool culture and all
get along well with each other and big
on uh you know connections and and
things like that so
for me that made it pretty easy just to
fit in
pretty well and and just help out where
i can like
with sully's situation bro like he's
i'm proud of him because he's one of
many like
he's just had the courage and shown you
know true strengths actually
first identify that you know he was
struggling and then actually seeking
help and if there can be more
you know solomon a la malu's out there
especially in our rugby community bro
the better and
um yeah i was like to just
spend a little bit of time with him and
just check through what i
you know some of the stuff i've been
through talking to you now and know that
um
yeah he's all good so i'm stoked to see
how he's all come through that brand
he's uh pissing down at south wind as
well but
yeah the whole whole environment down
there is was cool bro and you always
hear heaps of
good stories about the landers um
culture and the
and the connections that they drive down
there and it was cool to be a part of it
and what was it like going up against
the old foe the canes
um yeah very it was pretty interesting
like i think for where i was at that
time
like playing this year or even preseason
earlier this year like my main sort of
focus and headspace was just on
lowly me just getting out there and
getting back out on the footy field at
that level
just trying to
perform well and and just enjoy it as
opposed to like getting
too caught up i guess and like you know
my old team and ex teammates and guys
who are actually good friends so
um there wasn't too much banter going on
bro like it's yeah i was so much
respectful each of those boys like the
artie's and
and nani and each of those lads so um
yeah it wasn't
i felt here but i felt alright like
playing against him and
uh i think it was quite a hard case that
game in wellington
we kicked off and it was like the first
player they gave me box kicked back and
i went up for it and nani attacked me
but i had bobbled
well with the ball so i didn't get a
good clean catch on it and uh sort of he
bro he pretty much took me to ground
like
like he was probably putting his boy's
seal to grip like the beard like the
stove
cool this is going to be the shortest
game right i've ever played
he just like put me down to the ground
like so gently and i was just like what
the hell am i
i looked up at him brain he just gave me
like a wink
sure i small master the game i was like
where are you like
you took it easy on me and he was like
yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
how can i even repair you
just thank you so much for it but um
yeah that respect was
it was pretty high and um
yeah
i was pretty lucky i think
you're starting the game like that bro
so yeah always remember it made he was
saving you for the turbos you too
he is indeed and talk to me about your
little east coast cameo that looked like
good fun the other week oh bro that was
so much fun um
jose gear who
uh a legend and
new zealand rugby maori all black legend
all black believers and he took up the
coaching role last year for east coast
and
uh he sent me a message
earlier this year just asking my
movements around queen's birthday and
said if i wasn't up to much to go up to
the coast and play play for them in the
centenary celebrations and
um as the time got closer i just said to
them oh look where i've been playing
club down in dunedin um but if i'm not
about in the mix or not picked for
landers that week i'll see if i can um
talk to the coaches then come up
and anyway
yeah the stars aligned and um
yeah i was able to hear that head back
up home up to 20 and
laying there since canary
for my like gamepl in a way if that
makes sense like we're so fulfilling
just felt like real wholesome just being
like back up on the east coast um like
the field where you just see everyone
pull up on their
utes and everyone sitting on the back of
the trays on their trucks horses are
riding around the paddock just next to
the field
kids are running around like
just about running on the field when the
game's being played
uh just real like grass roots growing
um for me to spend a lot of time back up
that way when i was younger like
holidays and
where my mom's family's from was huge
and
used to watch east coast play back in
the late 90s early 2000s in their in
their glory years and
yeah to have the opportunity to put the
jersey on bro and play with a few few
relations and play in front of family
play back up home
uh foreign i was mean if i could do it
again like i yeah definitely i'm fit
right that's cool that's so cool that a
guy like you can go back to
east coast and um
give back to
a rugby community which obviously would
have been so stoked to have you involved
yeah bro now it was cool and uh got that
way like it's definitely more than a
game like it's a culture it's uh
almost like a religion up there in
the whole town of you know a couple of
thousand and reported the whole e they
all travel to the game and
um just to see how much sort of just the
atmosphere the
the buzz and the hype uh
how much sort of
talk there was leading up to the game
and then it's actually winter was quite
cool as well i think it was their first
best one in a few years so so to get a
dub for
what the coast was called for yeah not
only the team but
all the people and i think they
celebrated uh you know for a few days
after that as well which
is and a nicely inside bounce line from
you too oh yeah that was a we um we
played
sam parks the nine and then i was sort
of in our in our night before uh prep
for the game our one hour trip for the
games and our moves and stuff like that
here we just thought
we'll give this one a bit of a go and uh
you're lucky to get it pulled off oh
mate no wonder manuel got you coaching
you're a wizard even in an hour
but speaking of manual two like what
what are your plans going forward what
what's the plans for you um or i wanna
yeah obviously get back out on the field
enjoying this coaching camera role but
yeah i've still got strong motivations
about to keep playing the game uh
probably my you know ego and self-belief
is running on overdrive and i say that i
still want to play at the highest level
um
yeah i still back myself to
keep reaching new heights um
but i guess for the interim like right
now it's just about getting on the field
and then showing what i can do like or
if i get on the field and play crap
we'll have another conversation
and then i'll just
go straight into coach you gotta imagine
but
um yeah it's still still keen as bro to
keep playing and
um seeing where i can get to but then
like coaching or something as well that
i'm sort of
interested in and quite like you that
this role has popped up um to start
exploring that space and
obviously
um having some incredible mentors and
and coaches i've been under the
tutelage over the years you know i'm
able to draw on them and yeah use that
in coaching and
but also bring my own flavor to it as
well
nice and obviously your wife is very
successful actress as well and what's
her part of the plans has she got plans
for you how does that work pretty
annoying that we're in lockdown and she
can't be filming these big blockbuster
films that um
i think netflix has come to a bit of a
halt with all the
restrictions around um
quarantining and filming but now she's
she's put that on the on the back burner
from now they're filming um she's here
she's at a law firm in
in wellington so she's i don't know if
you'd say real mahi but but probably the
harder my he is yeah she's
working the nine to five plus hours that
that um lawyers
grind out these days and and the firms
so um
yeah now she's actually working from
home as we speak so i'm sort of running
the cutter i guess
oh how good is that
i thought you would
anyway mate as always we've gone to
instagram for some questions
gsat's been good stuff in there but i
know we've got a few questions come
through uh one of them was
you sort of just touched on it but what
has motivated you to keep going
um
i just started pushing myself like
um
i don't know if it's a
it's curiosity like just trying to
figure out you know
what i'm what i'm capable of like that
whole you know what's the word like
potential um
you know what even is there what are the
limits and yes probably like my wife
might say a different thing like going
through all the injuries and all the
setbacks and things she'll just want me
to
full pin and park up and i don't know
try to be a lawyer as well but um
i'm motivated by just
yeah wanting to keep testing myself keep
pushing myself then and see what
what my limits are with the elements
that that's here i'll be trying to build
some like favorite goggles or something
but
there's something comfortable like that
you both got some of them i see it's
both absolute beasts
okay have you ever thought about going
to the nrl yes yeah
did this happen a lot throughout your
career
um
yeah i did borrow like uh it was kind of
hard because rugby was sort of taking
off
but then it wasn't until might have been
after my
second shoulder injury where i was like
beginning to just try something new like
i was sort of entertaining all these
thoughts bro around just like pulling
pin like you know if i kind of over all
these injuries
um try something different and
yeah having that experience in the 20s
and i still love watching
um nrl go to the warriors um don't know
if i could go back now like it would be
a pretty pretty big ass but you know i
was always keen on trying to
just give it a crack and it was probably
from like not making nrl as well
you know
no good when you get out there go to the
nra david goggins that come on let's see
that i'd love to see you give it you
know crap jeez watch the space get some
league ceos on your podcast
okay
we got heaps of heaps of questions about
your side step as you could imagine who
was the hardest player to step
um
they're all easy for you eh it's like
the second one
no it's it's a long list of hard players
but i'd probably say um
probably malachi
yeah
yeah i was always not there at the
office [ __ ] one-on-one with him
because he just
i don't know if i should give away the
secret in terms of what he was doing but
uh he had to shut down my facebook
pretty much like he'd just get up real
fast and so
that'll just put me out of outer step
with my timing yeah
and so yeah there you go
make it hard for me
you are testing yourself i love that
your mindset to just keep growing
okay this one's from a young prodigy
reuben love how and when did you
practice you're stepping oh reuben love
geez he's the next up and come right how
and when
uh bro like
i don't know i'll probably get a bit of
stick for this but we had
these collections of like steinliker
these big sort of wooden boxes bro that
we had at home when i was a young fella
yeah um
obviously they were collected over many
many many years
but we used to have like a little sort
of rumpus room this little uh basement
space down at our house and i would set
them up for like
probably about
three meters apart from each other
and i'd be like in the room for about
like an hour hours bro just dipping just
going back and forth just pacing through
the house and
mob and that would be like come on
dinner i'm just like no no just 10 more
minutes just bro i just like stepped
sweating like coming out the thing like
what did we have to do down there
so he was just like 24 7
he was stepping down in like the rumpus
room these tiny um
cases or where i used to like
make an absolute
um mess of our back lawn like i put my
boots on and i'll just be like trying to
stick so hard that i'll try to live it's
in the ground that's right and i've been
so much trouble where i'd be hanging out
washing and i'll be stepping the clothes
on the clothesline
any
any opportunity i could get to spare for
like
probably even in like the supermarket
i'll be like stepping people in the
aisles and that so all right that's
crazy i always thought it was more of a
natural thing for you like you were just
sort of naturally gifted with this
amazing side step but you were working
hard on that craft since a young age
yeah sharpening that
that craft and
like back in the
vcr days and doing the videotapes like
we used to record games at bg marshall
um when he was playing for the tigers
like the early 2000's broadly just watch
there go outside practice five minutes
come back and watch another sidestep go
outside practice but i'll just be like
back and forth to the lounge watching
them and go outside and practice and
that's what i say to heaps like young
kids now when they ask me oh how did you
practice your step i might just go on
youtube
um
google me
i'm down the list i'll say sean johnson
benji marshall
um caleb
yeah bro there's so many and just
it's been like half an hour i just
watched them go out practice their
footwork what foot they jump off they
land what they do with you and there you
go
mate it's that easy she's
love that that's awesome
speaking of those two
um sean johnson and benji who would win
in a one-on-one on the seven meter
touchline you benji marshall or sean
johnson
oh definitely not me i'm just trying to
thank her out of
binge and sean
but i feel like binge is the the goat he
is uh
here's the ultimate burning up
yeah
i know maybe shawn might have like would
have been watching benji's clips back in
the day as as i was too so you probably
get the throne and the mantle to benji
oh fair enough is an absolute wizard uh
what is it like playing for the dragons
down in dunedin
yeah all the time
yeah a couple of good games done with um
zingery had one last year actually i
mean a few this year and
uh we actually went pretty good i know
there's a bit of a battle club
concerns the results but um yeah we
notched a few wins this year and there's
actually one that sticks out was um
valley he broke the record for the most
loved games i think it was over like 200
plus um and we got the win frame on that
day and there's a bit of a sky sport
little
all access oh nice
all access piece of belly and build up
the those record-breaking games so
marvel i enjoyed um enjoyed my time at
zingerie a lot of great people at that
club good stuff shout out to the dragons
okay
this one this is an interesting one from
the great man tim o'malley okay bruce
did you sign a tassie contract for 2021
drawn up the pub by bruce oh he sent
through the photo too unless he's forged
oh greasy geez that is um
that is that is correct but i don't know
if it's terms and conditions we had sort
of um
we laid out what the t's and c's were
and
yeah i don't know if it was a fish
fielder no
there might have been a few witnesses
present
yeah i signed some contracts in my time
oh i'm looking forward to working with
you when we come out of lockdown we'll
make that happen absolutely okay who is
the best winger of all time
um
the big girl owner
um
corey jane
uh
cheslin colby oh yeah servile like came
through different areas in a way like
siege might get a bit grumpy because you
probably haven't been chiseling out too
far apart but um
yeah like saturday
like jonah it's a jerusalem
like two completely different
players
body shapes different eras
um defensive systems and like skill sets
that we required back then versus now um
but then ultimately like who's just
carving up like chiseling is unreal for
the last few years um and then jono's
was an absolute weapon as well in this
time
so i'll probably yeah
probably put those two together
like that okay next one
um have you developed any effective
coping mechanisms during injuries and
what were they uh yep so
effective coping mechanisms a big one
for me is having a plan
so
what i struggle with is uncertainty
and
i struggle when i don't have
control when i'm not in control of
something
and so
um a good
mechanism for me is having a plan so
trying to
but
it could be just the plan for today
having a few key things that i want to
focus on and tip off my to-do list
[Music]
that helps me sort of stay in control of
what i
what i want to be doing um
what else with injuries
um
being able to talk to people about it
yeah
um it's it's a big one having people you
can trust whether it's you know a
partner or a good friend or
family member or professional support i
think being able to articulate and
actually express what you're feeling and
what your thoughts are
is real healthy like i know for me
that's what i struggled with was
actually i don't know
what i was feeling let alone how to
explain them let alone how to actually
overcome them
self-awareness is a big one so those are
probably two key big ones whereas having
a plan and then also
having that support and feeling like you
can talk to someone or knowing that you
should talk to someone about it
um yeah is key
it's powerful stuff
big fan of that okay last question this
will be good one piece of advice you
could give to any person in the world
one piece of advice um
just to be
be more
i don't know it's pretty like a cliche
for everyone but around like being kind
to yourself and being kind to others
um
whether that is like not being too put
to judge
yeah trying to just i'm trying to think
of like something straight to the point
like that's
without waffling on and giving you a
whole novel
like
yeah just being kind to yourself and
others
um and not being too quick to judge
america mate that is powerful that is
powerful stuff in it and a great way to
finish what has been one hell of a yarn
honestly really appreciate you coming on
the podcast and i'm giving an insight
into your career which has been an
amazing career i've loved following your
journey mate when i first met you and
the hurricane's water squad i knew you
were going to have a great career but
it's been quite hard to watch in terms
of the injuries i guess and seeing how
frustrating it can be i mean as a fan
and a friend it's been hard watching so
i can only imagine what it's been like
for you but what you're doing in the
space around mental awareness and um
being open with your struggles has been
so influential for so many people and
mate you're having a huge impact on not
only the rugby
community but new zealand's community as
well i think and
um so much respect for you as a person
for doing that so really appreciate you
coming on the podcast and giving up your
time mate oh no what a next legend what
it means for waterless um jimmy bar like
experiencing pleasure bro and i think um
what you're doing and what you know
there's a few other people out there
with the podcast like creating these
spaces for us
um you know myself and all the other
years you've had on and the ones you'll
continue to have
is actually to be able to speak in like
an open
non-judgmental world we'll see what the
comments come back with but
in a space you know where we can be sort
of ourselves and
and speak um authentically and actually
talk about our stories and our you know
those highs and lows because
um you know in terms of
you know i will say it traditional media
outlets and journalists um that's what
stops boys from actually being able to
say what's really going on is because
uh we don't control that narrative and
these other things other agendas at play
but
um so yeah what you're doing brown and i
hope you continue to do it just keep
giving
these young men and
young women all these faces to be
themselves and to talk to these stories
which will no doubt help um help others
and help the next generation coming
through bro so uh yeah now thank you and
yeah always reflect fondly of those
times back at the canes there's uh
having a mental like you bros
is uh yeah
kickstarter so um
thank you very much hey mate what a lad
really appreciate it bro look forward to
um having you down in tasman soon
man let me see what up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]